la régularisation concernerait environ
600 milles sans papiers tous ceux
travaillant illégalement en tant
qu'ouvrier agricole ou comme femme de
ménage et baby sitter depuis au moins le
31 octobre 2019 peuvent demander un
permis de séjour temporaire de 6 mois
mais pour obtenir le précieux sésame
plusieurs conditions sont imposés par
rome et les ressortissants étrangers
doivent auparavant avoir été soumis à
des contrôles photo dactyloscopiques en
clair empreintes digitales et photo
avant le 8 mars 2020 et ne pas avoir
quitté l'italie depuis cette date le
décret du gouvernement vise à offrir à
ses travailleurs sans papiers une
couverture santé et à combattre
l'inégalité
nous sommes arrivés à un résultat
important certainement mais aussi une
bataille de civilisation car je crois
réellement que la dignité des personnes
doit être au centre mais cela va aussi
de pair avec la lutte contre la
criminalité organisée
celle des marchands d'esclaves modernes
il ya aussi la mise au jour du travail
au noir mais également la sécurité et la
protection
nous sommes dans une situation
épidémiologique d'urgence sanitaire et
pour éviter justement la diffusion du
coronavirus le décret invite communes et
régions à prendre des mesures urgentes
pour garantir la salubrité la sécurité
des logements des migrants concernés une
main-d'oeuvre venus d'afrique du
moyen-orient mais également de pays
européens comme la bulgarie et la
roumanie pour récolter fruits et légumes
ou travailler à domicile
l'italie n'est pas le premier pays en
europe à prendre la décision de
régulariser des migrants fin mars le
gouvernement de gauche du portugal a
pris cette mesure pour permettre aux
étrangers en attente de régularisation
d'accéder aux soins et à toutes les
mesures sociales le temps de la crise
sanitaire du aux copies de 19 ans